[Music]
excited about fantastic beasts - you've
wrapped you guys are finished filming
what can you tell us about it playing
Dumbledore I mean how did you take on
that mantle do you know what I did I I
sat in a room for an afternoon with JK
Rowling and I listened to her
extraordinary words of wisdom and she
was kind enough to share with me the
whole back story and her future hopes
that this young that character of
Dumbledore and really that set me on the
path I just did what the writer said
everyone's very excited to see you and
Johnny Depp just go toe-to-toe in that
film yeah now congratulations on your
nomination I mean you're phenomenal and
the young Pope I am rooting for you
you've been nominated for a Golden Globe
for a time I see more money by the way I
know we're all talking about times up
but I think it's time it's time for you
to get a glow I'm just here to enjoy
myself I would agree with you but if you
know what I'm in an amazing group of
actors so I'm kind of fueled I mean any
any group that's headed by Robert De
Niro right or Jeffery right I mean all
of them are wonderful you and McGregor
is a very old friend of mine I knew him
when we were both starting out in London
we shared a flat together so isn't that
funny things we go way back so it's a
wonderful group and I'm very happy just
to be in that company and like I said to
be here tonight to enjoy it but also to
be here and to raise awareness for a
really important cause you're supporting
time's up why was that so important for
you I think it's important a night like
this where we are celebrating our work
is also an opportunity to be in
solidarity with the men and women who
have been brave enough to raise
awareness of an issue that our industry
needs to reform above them so I am very
proud to be you know I made a donation
and I'm very proud to be here supporting
it as a cause
[Music]
you